stocking up on the essentials can be
hard to do with inflation and product
shortages all around us one local
non-profit has reopened its doors to
help out Madison Kimbrough is live in
our Newsroom with everything hope Cove
has to offer Madison Sasha today I heard
from the founder who is ecstatic to be
serving the community once again after
being closed due to lack of funds and
hope Cove is back with an abundance of
supplies take a look
I don't care if it's a 250 breast pump
or a two dollar binky
it's free that was Tammy Dukey founder
of Hope Cove a non-profit organization
doing a lot of good for families in the
community Tammy a lactation consultant
opened hope Cove in 2020 out of her home
and now three years later is pleased to
see it back open at a new property
located on Flamingo Road we provide
completely free baby supplies for
at-risk families so diapers formula
wipes breast pumps breastfeeding
supplies postpartum items baby bottles
pacifiers and family hygiene Tammy fully
reliant on the Vegas Community for help
in order to continue operating whether
it be from people donating products or
through the use of local grant money mom
of two Aaliyah lukerson is beyond
thankful for the services hope cope
provides I think think it's great for
moms to have
in the valley because you just never
know what someone's going through you
know so you know like for me example I'm
unemployed so
um you know Financial hardships you know
times are hard or you know there's a lot
of single moms out there and supplies
fully accessible to every type of family
that's Tammy's Mission at Hope Cove I
have from the 15 year old mom
all the way up through the 80 year old
grandma who's raising her children's
children
and everything in between
and as far as getting the process in
supplies hope Cove doesn't require any
proof of income or documentation in
order to receive items now for now the
nonprofit is open on Sundays that's from
10 a.m to 5. in The Newsroom Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now